okay so in today's video we're going to
discuss the difference between what is
HIV and then what is AIDS so let's go
ahead and get started okay so let's
start with with some information about
the HIV virus so you know what is HIV
well here is a picture here this is the
virus you can see it has some strands of
RNA on the inside one of the red circles
is labeled reverse transcriptase that's
a very special enzyme that the HIV virus
possesses and will see its job in a
little bit but HIV stands for human
immunodeficiency virus human because it
infects humans immunodeficiency because
it weakens our immune system we'll
explain how in just a little bit and
then it's a virus now a virus is a
parasite that lives inside of our cells
that's what an intracellular parasite is
and it's in the category of a retrovirus
now these are RNA viruses that contain
reverse transcriptase and turn their RNA
backwards into DNA and we'll see how it
does that in a little bit as far as some
characteristics of the HIV virus first
of all the HIV virus only attaches to
and really infects a type of white blood
cell known as a t-cell that's really
important because T cells are the cells
that will send signals to activate your
body's immune system whenever they
detect an intruder like the virus or
bacteria here's a picture of a t-cell
the big blue Cushie thing is the T cell
and all those little or golden yellow
dots are are multiple HIV viruses that
have attached to this one particular T
cell and so as time passes the HIV virus
actually destroys these T cells and the
amount of T cells that the person has
begins to dwindle so an uninfected
individual will have anywhere from 500
to 1628
T cells in every cubic millimeter of
blood but when a person is diagnosed
with the disease known as AIDS they have
less than 200 of these T cells per cubic
millimeter of blood and so eventually
our immune system becomes compromised
our immune system is greatly reduced
therefore opportunistic infections such
as by other viruses and bacteria could
actually make the person very very ill
to the point where it could take their
life so how is HIV contracted you know
this pie graph right here comes from the
Centers of Disease Control based on the
year 2007 and it really shows the two
high risk activities very well number
one is in sexual activity the biggest
portion of the graph making up fifty two
point eight eight percent on the graph
is through homosexual male sex MSM in
the keys and for men having sex sex with
men and then the next biggest part of
the graph representing about 32% is
through heterosexual sex and then the
next biggest part of the graph eleven
point six two percent is labeled IBU and
this stands for intravenous drug users
so there are various drugs that require
the drug to be injected into a vein and
so quite frankly quite frequently drug
users will inject one person with one
needle and then they inject multiple
people using the same needle and and
that's one way to spread the virus
so if we look at some of the low-risk
ways in which the HIV virus may be
contracted you know if a woman is
pregnant
there are antiviral medications that she
can take to help keep the virus at such
a low amount that the chance of it Pat
being passed on to her unborn child is
very very low but there is a small
chance that it still could happen when
if a woman is HIV positive and she's
recently given birth then because the
virus has been found in breast milk then
she would be advised not to breastfeed
her child and this is a this was a
problem especially in the 1980s before
we really understood how HIV was spread
but there's countless incidences where
people were people had contracted the
HIV virus through through receiving some
sort of blood product whether it was a
blood transfusion or plasma or
hemophiliacs receiving treatment for
hemophilia but with today's improved
screening methods this problem is
virtually been eliminated so let's look
at the HIV lifecycle how does the HIV
virus go about replicating and infecting
well if we break this down into a few
steps here is my white little blob in
the picture this is a t-cell so type of
a white blood cell so here's a t-cell
now the HIV virus will only attach to
receptors that are found on t-cells so
here comes the HIV virus in yellow and
it just attached to a receptor on the
surface of a t-cell so what happens next
is the host cell the t-cell will
actually draw the virus inside notice
how the capsid dissolved thus exposing
the RNA of the virus and that red circle
labeled RT for reverse transcriptase so
reverse transcriptase is an enzyme and
what does enzyme directs is that the
process of transcription in Reverse now
normally
the route of transcription is where DNA
is converted into RNA but this is called
reverse transcriptase because it does
reverse transcription so what happens is
reverse transcriptase will take the RNA
of the virus and in a backwards
transcription process create DNA of the
virus so what happens to that DNA of the
virus well the DNA the virus will
actually integrate into the host cell's
DNA and form what's called a provirus
this combination of host DNA and viral
DNA
well now what happens that the HIV viral
DNA has integrated into the host host
cell's DNA well
the viral DNA will actually recreate a
bunch of viral RNA HIV RNA as it seeds
created and then it exits the nucleus
and attaches to a ribosome of the host
cell well you should know at this point
that ribosomes build proteins and
viruses are big balls of protein so now
the ribosomes have the instructions to
make new viruses which are then released
to then infect another cell so here we
see it a third ribosome creating a third
HIV virus which is then released to
infect more cells and ultimately
eventually this weakens the T cell to
the point where it is destroyed and this
is why over time the amount of T cells
in the person's blood begin to drop and
drop and drop here's a picture of a of a
t cell with about a dozen HIV viruses
budding out and being released to the
outside world actually not to the
outside world but to the outside of this
particular cell and so what is then AIDS
if we now understand what H
he is HIV is a virus what is ate well
the HIV virus causes the condition or
the disease known as AIDS and aids
stands for the acquired immunodeficiency
syndrome acquired because you have to
acquire the virus and it makes your
immune system deficient and so the
diagnosis of AIDS is typically made when
in a person with HIV is seeing the
doctor for regular physical exams and
eventually when the t-cells are measured
in the person's blood when the t-cells
are less than 200 T cells per cubic
millimeter of blood earlier I showed you
that an uninfected individual has
anywhere from 500 to 1,600 to cells per
cubic millimeter of blood now it might
take years it could take years for the
normal amount to kind of dwindle to
below 200 T cells per cubic millimeter
of blood at which time the person would
be diagnosed with AIDS but a lot can
happen in those years that the person's
t-cells might be dropping the person
might not even know they have the virus
and so they may continue with the risky
behaviors that were previously mentioned
and another way to be diagnosed with the
condition of AIDS is even though they
might have higher than 200 T cells per
cubic millimeter of blood the person
just might be showing multiple symptoms
and multiple infections that you see
from the list here in the photograph and
in the descriptions you know so what are
some ways to prevent the spread of the
HIV virus and to hopefully prevent the
condition the syndrome known as AIDS
well really it comes down to sexual
health and understanding how HIV is
transmitted knowing that HIV is
transmitted through unprotected
I want to mention that abstinence is the
only 100% effective form of birth
control and here we have pictures of
purity ring's where some people may make
a pledge not to have premarital sex
until their until they are married for
those people who are sexually active
latex condoms are the only forms of
birth control that now not only protect
against pregnancy but also prevent the
spread of STDs sexually transmitted
diseases such as HIV and of course be
tested it's really important if you look
at the picture there's a website here
for more information but you can be
tested anonymously through various
clinics or you could also of course see
your family doctor and then for
intravenous drug users that was the
other high-risk activity of course if
you have a loved one who you are
concerned with their risky behavior
encourage treatment encourage rehab
facilities and now this might be a
little you know controversial right here
but some health care facilities some
community outreach programs might exist
in your area that actually encourage
needle exchanges the logic being well if
they're going to use intravenous drugs
at least they might be able to use them
safely by using clean needles every time
so you just have to check your area to
see if in your area needle exchanges are
offered of course I do want to stress
however the the you know the
encouragement of your loved one in to
treatment facilities or rehab facilities
you know before I finish I want to
mention the AIDS quilt because I think
it's a wonderful way that's been used
over the years to raise awareness and
education involving the AIDS epidemic
that we currently show you so here's a
piece of the AIDS quilt you can see it's
been decorated to remember a loved one
and what happens is the AIDS quilt
panels are sewn together with other
panels so here are eight panels sewn
together or now what you can see the
eight panels are bundled together with
others eight times four here are 32
panels that have been sewn together and
these panels travel the world and are
used to raise awareness and educate and
to remember loved ones who've lost their
lives through their struggles with HIV
and eight you know currently there are
tens of thousands of panels that have
been created as part of the AIDS quilt
so again just a wonderful way to
remember lost lives and loved ones who
have struggled through their clear
infection with the HIV virus so there
you have it if you want to try this
practice quiz go ahead and pause the
video and if you're in my class I can
check your answers before or after
school one day and to see how you did so
go ahead and pause the video and I hope
you found this helpful